cannes allons-y c'était aujourd'hui
l'événement du jour bien sûr surtout
pour la première fois depuis 21 ans un
film français a remporté la palme d'or
c'est sous le soleil de satan de pialat
je rêve du four dans un instant va
revenir sur les grands prix du palmarès
le temps d'abord que de vous rappeler
quelques uns des prix moins prestigieux
mais tout aussi importants par exemple
le prix du jury qui étale ex-aequo aux
films lumière du malien souleymane cissé
et le film xinran du japonais mieko dit
alors vont revenir à la palme d'or ce
qu'il faut dire c'est qu'elle a été très
contestée c'est vrai il ya eu des remous
et des sifflets après l'annonce et
maurice pialat en répondant à été vous
allez le voir fidèle à son personnage
si vous ne m'aimez pas je peux vous dire
que je ne vous aime pas non plus
je crois simplement ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que pialat est un homme sensible
ces films en témoignent bien sûr et ce
n'était sans doute qu une manière
peut-être maladroite de traduire
l'émotion qu'il ressentait alors